Miriam scared of the water I don't know
how she's gonna date a guy in the coast
god you know we all get scared out there
I'm not afraid of the water Bernie he
scares me at night that's all you can't
see what's underneath just more water 18
foot fracture in the hole and he wants
to proceed
you know the same it's gonna be the
biggest storm that ever hit the East
Coast it's gonna be hurricane strength
in an hour call this what are you wait
so long before you suggest they're going
out on the date I just didn't know if
you'd be attracted to me you know
exactly how I pictured you yeah
what's this all the radio [ __ ] break it
up
she's a t2 tanker split right in half
we've got maybe two three hours and then
we sink chief pick yourself a crew you
assist that ship here so I signed up
yes now's my chance man and I don't know
what he's doing he's sending you wanted
to die the Coast Guard they say you
gotta go out they don't say you got to
come back in dust it Bernie go out on
the rescue I'm worried about Carl so no
one's getting over the bar in this
weather it's a suicide mission
please tell me we're taking that boat to
a bigger boat
you don't know what it's like out there
please call him back in you can't be in
here miss
we're supposed to get married you're
gonna come in here scared every time
he's out in the water
please call him back watch he's got his
orders get her out of here there's
something about to die
brace yourselves
you